[Music]
Kim kardashian-west she stepped out in
New York City last night and Michelle
was there and you know what Michelle for
Kim this was pretty covered up right
well yeah it was but it was still pretty
sexy now Kim received a big fashion
honor at the CFDA Awards but she also
got real with me about her man Kanye
airing their dirty laundry and his new
music I said slavery a choice this you
didn't let him off the hook
a wife Karla screaming say we've got to
lose it all bond of us were wondering
like what's tempting Reza did she talk
to him about it did she care about that
that I fight about it yeah yeah I mean
it's like that's not stuff we put on
social media Kanye even went after Chris
and Khloe's men Chris to me was what get
just a single sometimes you got a bag to
bust up I call that ticket Corbett
Gamble's
but his track wouldn't leave referencing
issues in their marriage kind of shocked
mrs. West told us she could leave me now
but she would
that was the one song that he didn't
really play from me and some last minute
he likes scrap just full album and reads
it it in the last two weeks and just
came up with all new songs I'd love to
go home for like two days and then I
come back and it was a whole new album
so I was like okay yeh has racked up
over 100 million streams and the album
alludes to mental illness
the cover art reads I hate being bipolar
it's awesome I've seen him go through a
lot he might say things that might get
misinterpreted we have different views
sometimes we have different things but
that's my husband you know I'm about as
fashionable as Kanye is black that joke
was my choice just like slavery come on
tonight's host Issa Rae threw some shade
but told me his wife deserves the
influencer award I mean the influencer
award there's no doubt that Kim K
influence an entire abetting I'm kind of
shocked that I'm winning a fashion award
when I'm naked most of the time but most
Kourtney and Kendall there to support
their sister Oprah was a surprise
presenter but where was Kanye he's
working on another album and I needed
someone to watch the kids City on it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]